[Applause]
[Music]
luno the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's
the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to my show
today is going to be
really interesting so just bear with us
because this is powered by
icon plus so a really quick news
announcement for you so this quarter
icon will not only launch d5 projects
omn finance and balance but also
upgrade to icon 2.0 so this will be
really interesting
now this is um sponsored by blockbuy you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on your usdc um on your usdc i
said that really weirdly
um and you can actually get i think it's
around 250 when you sign up
so check that out now guys if you are
watching on youtube please don't forget
to hit the subscribe button
hit the like button so you never miss
any of these interesting
guests now today for the very first time
we actually have somebody who is just a
little bit younger than me usually i'm
always the youngest in the room
but it is young investor how are you
doing zach
what's up thanks hand me on yeah of
course i've just been seeing you around
seeing you grow
so much online and i'm kind of just
amazed that you're 13 right
yeah 13 now so i have so many questions
for you
um and i kind of just want to start
really with
being 13 and being in you know stocks
and crypto and all this stuff is so
unusual
so you must get people who are so
surprised when you tell them you're 13.
what's the first reaction
you get well it's kind of like
so you know you get you get your
goodness bad side of people you know
you've got your haters then you've got
like the 99 of people who are really
positive
so like obviously all the positive
people always like that you know that's
amazing
i'm really surprised i mean right now
i've done like three straight interviews
on my youtube channel but i didn't want
ross gerber
he runs a 1.6 billion dollar hedge fund
and gally from hyperchange and i just
got daily on investing on
and then you know everyone's commenting
about saying how much they love the
guests on
so it's all going really really well
right now and just there's not a
surprise
it's also not people who just you know
are really
um in a sense they just think well you
know it's
how can you be into stocks at that young
age and you're
somebody put in the comments the other
day and he i my dad used to tax me 13
when i was like at his age on all my
winnings
so yeah so you know you always get your
mixed reactions but
all 99 always positive i'm just so
blown away because you know you're on
twitter which is just
really just an adult's playground like
that's just the truth of it
and how do you find it how do you find
that
you know especially there's a lot of
different ideas on there there's a lot
of
um conversations you know it gets very
political
um crypto gets really political stocks
get really political so
how do you find sort of navigating
through that and interacting with
everyone
yeah well i think if you're on twitter
you've always got to be prepared for you
know a bit of hate or else don't be on
twitter you know i think you
this kind of thing where if you're
really sensitive about something then
you've just shouldn't be on twitter but
i think chris is such a place with so
many fluid conversations happening
you know you have one person about
crypto one person talking about stocks
two people have both long bitcoin
arguing about bitcoin i think it's
actually a fascinating place to see
other people's opinions and perspectives
on the world
in general whether that's from stocks
crypto or anything else maybe somewhere
abroad
or um you know current events you always
get everyone's perspective on twitter
i think that's what really makes the
platform special
okay so what about your friends you know
are they
into this as well or do they think what
you're doing is absolutely nuts and
insane
yes i mean my friends aren't you know
don't really care to be honest
they're just kind of like i'll call them
you know we'll do our normal stuff
whatever we do
so if i go you know for a little for a
ride with one of them
you know socks doesn't come up in the
conversation or crypto
because it's one most complicated and
boring things in the entire world
if you don't know anything about it you
know so i think if you just stay away
from that kind of conversation topic
constantly then you know it's it's all
fun and games really
yeah i love that i love that attitude
even in my own life my friends are not
interested in bitcoin whatsoever
um so yeah you just you just stay away
from it so okay so you say
it's you know boring to everyone else so
how did you first get into it
yeah so i used to be a really full
full-blown history geek
and you you're sure you know the
rothschilds they built the very first
ever network which would be able to
communicate the best news really quickly
say the whole team of messengers which
will communicate the wins so when
napoleon was against the duke of
wellington
in the battlefields of france in
waterloo obviously we won that battle
which then
saved us from french invasion but the
ross child sent a messenger back to
london
because everyone used to rely on their
network as most reliable
and quickest even quicker than the
military's network when they came to
london they said that we lost the battle
of water though
the stock market proceeded to plunge 80
percent as everyone wanted to get their
money out
and flee abroad before the french
marched on london and then
obviously the rothschilds completely
lied and brought up all the stocks when
they were down 80
a few people actually caught on to it on
the stock exchange and started buying it
up as well
and obviously in stock market
immediately around rebounded
the rothschilds made a whole lot of
money so it's kind of things with that
when you hear about all this kind of
stuff in history
which really inspired me to fight open a
stock market account
and then further on and then a crypto
account
so given you know you're doing all this
stuff and you've obviously opened up the
crypto account
and things like that what i'm really
interested in asking you about
really is is there any financial
education
in school i know you've probably been
out of school for ages because of covert
and all that stuff but do they talk
about this in school these days i mean
you know bitcoin's going crazy
is it even on the syllabus yeah so i've
been at school for about three or four
weeks now
and i've just finished now for easter
holidays for two weeks
so you never hear a word about stocks or
bitcoin at school there's nothing
there's no kind of financial education
at all
this sets up so the education system
really lacks i mean
i think you know investing and investing
just where that's bitcoin whether that's
another asset
it's just the key to grow wealth in the
future and you're older and older you
get
it's just simple math by compound
interest wherever you want to take a
risk and invest in so much bitcoin which
might be more speculative
or not for your risk tolerance whether
you want to invest in something which i
don't know might be the s p 500 index
funds
either one of those ways is really a way
to grow wealth now i do think that lacks
in the current education system
so do you think that they're ever gonna
bring that in
do you think that do you feel a need to
sort of because like you said it's the
best way to grow wealth and
you know um ensure your future and so on
so do you think that eventually they're
gonna bring that in and also do you
suddenly feel like a moral need
to share your wisdom with your friends
and other people at school with you
yeah i mean um i do think that it
depends you i think you need someone in
government he's just all really into
this kind of stuff
to have that push through so i kind of
doubt it comes into the education system
in the near future
it's lacked in the education system last
like 100 years
you know these days it's kind of thing
where you know the whole modern
environment has changed
back when my name was alive in world war
ii you know when they
didn't have running water hot water and
then the bomb then the bombs were
falling down
compared to now when it's all online or
technology hence you're streaming live
onto twitter and youtube all through
technology or for computers
cameras so i think it's just really an
era of which has changed
so the education has changed with that
era but i do think that one thing which
hasn't really changed
just financial education to people i
mean i my friends like know about all my
socks and all that but i don't i don't
push it just because i feel like
if it's not something you're interested
in it's not something you're really
really interested in
i think it's always kind of a bad idea
if you constantly push it on someone
because then you don't get any friends
because i think you've got listen to
what other people think
about what their interests are as well
but i do think that
um when i put my stuff out on twitter
youtube where there might be i always
hope that some
some kids somehow get inspired i was out
in my um
in the precinct like a few weeks it's
like yeah last sunday
and some kid who looked how like looked
like he's about 11 came up to me and
said hey you're a young investor
i was like wow yeah and that was the um
i said he said oh he loves my youtube
live streams i've never met him before
so that's that's that's that's the only
other time i've been recognized but it
was um
pretty cool it's just seeing like that
how you inspire people to get into
investing
you know i think it's absolutely
phenomenal more and more people
investing
the more and more wealthier you're going
to be in that sense and the quicker you
can retire and
the longer you can be retired for
instead of working like the whole 60
years of your life is you know the
retirement age carries on going up
okay so how do you have this wisdom
though like how do you know about that
because look you're talking about
inflation you're talking about early
retirement
you're talking about things which a lot
of people only in their mid-20s come to
so i'm in my mid-20s and i'm i feel like
i'm quite lucky
because i kind of figured this out when
i was about 22
and i think that's really really young
um so how on earth did you come to all
of this wisdom i mean
did your parents talk to you about you
know i don't know
early retirement because also with all
this you know
following and with all with this
following that you have and
with um because you have a really
engaged following so with this and
following
that that you have and you know with all
this
financial wisdom and all this investing
you're carving out the most incredible
future for yourself
yes so my parents like know nothing
about finance especially my mother
wow yeah i started investing just from
like i described earlier about all about
history and i mean
i had like nuclear what i was doing it
was awfully kind of youtube how i
learned
how to invest and through the odds like
books so you can see a book by
peter lynch back there so it's kind of
just for youtube i do think youtube's
kind of the new university you can learn
everything you really learn at
university on youtube so i really
learned everything about
the stock market on youtube so it's kind
of progressed from the stage where nine
or nine or ten months ago
i was just investing in whatever so now
it's kind of like i actually dig deep
into companies i might get to see on my
channel
and actually dig a dig deeper and take
that next step into researching
into companies and actually deciding
which ones are the frauds and which ones
are the next big thing
and you know next really 10x opportunity
in the markets
so so that's really how i just look at
it all and
i mean my the only other time my dad's
invested was something like
40 years ago when hit my dad put some
money into like virgin group or
something when the ibo
ipos yeah i think it's like he was like
20 then
but in the richard branson ticket like
public that's private again one week
later because of share price didn't do
what he hoped
so um i kind of off like
maybe a month after investing i got my
dad into it i think he's like yeah
i love that yeah so now hopefully it's
more more and more people get into
investing you know the
more wealth you grow and all in like
long 30 or 40 year time span
so given what you said about university
you know youtube is the
is the new university especially if
you're not
you know if you're not doing something
like medicine and law
then everything else i think generally
speaking is good on youtube
so do you have what are your plans do
you have plans no one have even thought
about it
and do you have plans to go to
university or are you just building you
yeah i mean i i just take it as it goes
i mean right now
i've got my money and all my cryptos and
my stocks on one side so it's kind of
like
more and more you build that i'm aiming
for a kind of aggressive
but hopefully i won't one year salary by
the time at 18 saved up
so that's kind of the way you do where
i'm trying to not try not to go
university in that sense
i mean if i want to go university it's
always there there's no time limit
as soon as you're like 25 you can't go
university it's always there if i want
to
but maybe you know take it take it as it
goes in time
yeah i think i can't give you any advice
i can just give you
really informal opinions which is ditch
university and just do what you're doing
honestly i just think what you're doing
is so amazing you're obviously so
intelligent
and i think everyone is just like so
impressed so
how do you pick a stock then what are
the best stocks for 2021
i mean the the really first way i look
at stocks is you know as long as the
financials are sound
it's got at least really like two years
worth of cash from the balance sheet
or it's going to have enough in profit
to boost that up i'm trying to look for
companies in the lowest which are
growing super high growth
and extremely undervalued compared to
the amount of money or revenue they're
going to make this year
we're going to try and get as low as the
p as possible so if you look at
something like i don't know upstart so
which is like 20 pa
i don't invest in that kind of company i
want to invest in a company which is
like
super undervalued whether that's on otc
markets whether it's just on the normal
exchanges but saying which has just been
super
um overlooked by investors so right now
one of my biggest high conventional
trades right now
it's a company called peak fintech
holdings they're gonna be uplifting to
the nasdaq in a few weeks and
they basically are in china and they
allow
small family-run businesses to connect
with these massive lenders in china
and take some take small loans out
between them so that will
help boost like the family business for
example but when the chinese lenders
aren't all online are
on all advanced as technology is right
now
they are enabling that to happen there's
also canadian technically canadian based
it's founded by a canadian person called
jj so you've got that risk where you
don't get the d
listing because it's based in canada not
in china so you don't get kind of trying
to delisting fiasco
they are expected i would i estimate
around 250 million dollars in revenue
this year
i'll expect for guidance in a few weeks
ever say around 150
and you know for the last few years they
always set their expectations super low
for kind of the
um you know settle kind of over deliver
not um over
promise and under deliver so that's
really kind of their whole
moral to you know so investors are in
sense
more pleased than rather all
disappointed when you might be with some
specs at the moment which aren't
reaching
those kind of highs that you want them
to so companies are around 320 million
dollars right now
so if they were to get 250 million in
revenue it's just a super cheap market
cap
market cap right now you know 10 pe or
11 is really not unreasonable
on a company growing as fast as this 600
year-over-year
if they hit 250 million this year and so
like 300
last year so you're in an industry where
and all kinds of growth rates it's
fintech
and you've got super ips super high
things which are pricing in
a lot of the growth compared to coming
like this is super undervalued in the
whole marketplace
so that's really how i can look pick
socks i'm looking for the ones which are
super
overlooked you know you don't you when i
look at peak fintech there's no articles
about them
you've got to really do and really deep
digging and that's kind of
stock i want i don't think there's
hardly any analysts covering out and i'd
like zero analysts
covering the stock at all which is one
of the best times to invest
because the smart money isn't in yet
uplifts the nasdaq
means institutions start to buy in 50
million race to complete institutions
so then that won't affect the float
which is the amount of which can be
traded on a daily basis
those institutions will be locked up so
they won't be able to trade this
stock which will mean there's no
pressure on the current stock price
with a float right now it just adds to
the outstanding shares which
which combined will equal the whole
market cap so i'm just looking for a
super overlooked company
super undervalued which has a super high
growth trajectory
and would you call yourself i know
obviously you've called yourself young
investor but do you
are you more of a trader then or an
investor like how long are you holding
on to these stocks
yeah so with the kind of like tests
which is not like 40 of my stock
portfolio that's kind of a free
four-year long-term poll for me
that's kind of the backbone that's the
strength you know super bullish from
tesla
what they're doing is actually
transforming the world ev's thomas
driving us all the future they're far
ahead then all the competition and
behind them
and you know look at gm look up for
they're not taking the ev revolution
seriously
so tess is kind of the backbone at 40
percent strong company
super bullish on it super bullish on
elon so that's with that so that's there
at 40
then something like um peak fintech
which might be a maybe a one to two year
hold
so something like that this is more
speculative if for example at 5x
tomorrow or like 5x in the next year
then i'd really kind of reassess the
whole situation with peak
what they're gonna make next year and
this is kind of the point where harry
said this is a bit overvalued now
i would sell out and if it's not i would
keep unit out of something like went to
like that 40
of my portfolio if it's still in kind of
the fair price range for peak
and if i was just getting into stock i'd
be buying it at those kind of prices
so with some like tesla which is just
super long term i might evaluate like
just three as
three other stocks which are like the
main holes in my portfolio are komodo
which is an ev company clean smart which
is basically
transforming the micro grids microgrids
enable you to
so in the main power grid goes down
slowly over time microgrids have been
draining power from whether that's your
solar panels
or the main network and that can keep
your house military and military base
carrying running for a certain amount of
time combined with this they recently
brought a bitcoin mining division
so they're gonna aim to scale up to
seven eight bitcoins a day that same as
mara
but mars like five six x higher than
clean sparking valuation
and just with that they're combining the
microgrids and the bitcoin mining to try
and make the lowest cost of
mining bitcoin in the industry which
then means on top of that you can then
license
all this technology to all the other
bitcoin players so that's even more
revenue on top of bitcoin mining and
micro grids
then you're also doing bitcoin licensing
or the mining so i'm just looking for
something which is super undervalued
but if there's a company which may be
more speculative so which isn't a tester
in my portfolio
that's where i i re-evaluate it every
single earnings
and see if the story's changed is his
stories changed and you want to get out
of it
if it's no longer what you are um
wanting the trajectory
for the company to go on and if it's not
then you keep and then you hold
so you mentioned the three that take up
the majority of your portfolio right now
but
what would you potentially can you name
on some stocks that you're looking at
for the next
for the rest of 2021 can you give us any
clues yeah
so so my main stock right now for 2021
is peak i just think peaks are
undervalued it is one thing with it
everything went into the domino effect
that could be a 10x stock in like two
years
if the market picks up on it and starts
to realize it and as soon as you get the
up list and the nasdaq
just how undervalued it is it's
absolutely insane to me
but then i think just in 2021 i'm
looking at some of the specs right now
i do think a lot of them are like super
um overvalued so i'm just looking at
maybe some more companies like forest
road acquisition which is managing
beachbody
and so they they're gonna be taking
three companies like mrx
fitness as well so that's kind of a
competitive peloton and they're going to
be putting them
all under this one umbrella company
which is going to be making like similar
revenues to palestine and pedestrians
like
so they're going to publish a few
billion dollar evaluation person's doing
something like i don't know they're like
40 billion right now so i'm just
so i'm watching them right now obviously
i think at the moment i'm just
focusing on four core positions right
now that's tesla
clean spock akamoto and peak okay
i like it and you mentioned bitcoin so
you have to tell me how you initially
got into
cryptocurrency um and also do your
parents
you know your parents must know what
you're investing in do they have any
concerns about crypto at all
no my parents don't really know what
crypto is so okay there you go
yes so how did you first hear about it
yes i mean
loads of my followers are all i was kind
of into bitcoin like two months
like nine months ago i hadn't really
heard of it so i hadn't really done much
research but then my followers were into
when i started picking up on the amount
of followers and
all of them were like really into
bitcoin so i also do a load of research
into bitcoin ethereum i do it all on the
network
and honestly i've come to the conclusion
of the last few months bitcoin is
digital gold
that is okay that's the currency which
we use to store value on the digital
network
people don't want to see the mass
inflation like 40 or those like the last
two years
uh have all been printed in the us they
don't want to have their money
constantly devalued as prices go up
they want to have a safe sort of value
and then they can actually transact
in in the sense instead of having a gold
bar which you've got a store
and if you don't have enough space to
store all your gold bars they've got
paid to store it
competitors all secure online so more
and more as bitcoin matures then you get
that price volatility coming down
i've also concluded theorems digital
gold you get nfts you get tokens
so this whole network which is built
around the theorem of just
all this kind of different funky weird
stuff there's come there's one called
uni socks which you just buy like socks
or actual socks
i haven't seen that actually yeah so
that's uni socks i
i've got like i don't know 100 bucks
it's super sensitive but basically uni
socks were
done by the thing called uni swap which
is one of the creators in the
um ethereum network which is creating
code for it
and they issued much one time about a
year a year ago something
so the merch is all it's actual socks
i did see this i remember yeah all has
uni socks on it
so they sold it for about 12 bucks
they're not nice you know no no they're
nothing special just socks of uni socks
on it yeah
just about a year a year and a half ago
they sold it for 12 bucks i think that's
like
8 800 000 it hit a high of 136 thousand
dollars
for a pair of socks which is which is
kind of insane it says about like 478 of
them right now
which haven't been redeemed so if you
get what if you have like one pair of
socks
you can redeem like one pair of socks
you can actually wear them and have it
all sent to your dress for free
so that's really the whole concept
unison so it's just one of those smaller
things
in the whole network which is super
duper funky it's just got so many use
cases around the theorem
but there is going to be more of a case
so you're going to have this nfts
you're going to have all this kind of
stuff built around it but then people
aren't going to be
people will be buying ethereum as a
store of value but also in a sense to be
able to transact on the whole network
itself
so okay so so many interesting things
there so firstly i do remember the socks
um that was pretty crazy i remember when
that came out but
okay so bitcoin you obviously see is as
digital gold you mentioned ethereum as a
store of value that's really
interesting um because a lot of people
sort of see
bitcoin more as that store of value and
ethereum
there's like currency kind of thing yeah
like network itself in my opinion
yeah just you know like programmable
money and
well somebody wants to put it to me like
this somebody wants to put it to me as
um bitcoin is gold and ethereum is
amazon the same way you can literally at
this point do anything on amazon whether
it's you know
watch a film um buy things you know and
those two things are completely
different so where do you see
all the other cryptocurrencies you know
are would you obviously not a bitcoin
maximalist you obviously see a lot of
value in
d5 and nfts so tell me where you see the
most value
i think nfc is a bubble i think all
great things start with the bubble we
saw a bitcoin back in 2017.
my opinion on nfts is a sense it's just
one so over hope now
and i think they will crash eventually
but then in five years six years down
the road
you're going to see another surge in nf
teaser like we saw in bitcoin
like we saw all the other
cryptocurrencies back in the day i think
all great things
started the bubble and then it's slowly
going to build its way back up as we've
seen the bitcoin this year
and in 2020 it started to all build it
about itself it back up from this kind
of 2017 2018 kind of crashes from its
all-time highs
it's like 18 000 and then you have
everything like selling out of it
and so now in the sense bitcoin is now
owned by institutions bitcoins now owned
by tesla
which is an s p 500 company it's been
now officially hated
in a sense where back then in 2017 it
wasn't like mainstream accepted by the
whole society
i think nfts is not having a flow of
institutional money coming into it
so i do think some nfts will survive and
will be valuable
some of the original nfts a majority of
them will lose more or less all their
value
and maybe in a few years they want to
really stand out which innocence are
actual artwork
you know there's no art but on on the
digital if somebody sees a value in the
piece of art because they think it's a
phenomenal piece of
art they actually love it it's all on
digital and they want to own that one
copy of it
all online and they could buy that nft
so you'll see that you're actually going
to have
in the future way more kind of entity
artists
in a sense you're going to see your bank
season they're all going to be
developing on nfts
this is all six years down the road it's
not now i think it's all starting to
become a bit like
you've got load of entities out it's
kind of just pointless
and it goes for hundreds and hundreds of
thousands so
and that's why i really do see nfts i
think the biggest store of value
in the cryptocurrency right now which
will make the most is bitcoin
i think yeah when my price tag on
bitcoin's 300 000
i'm just doing it around the market have
gold right now so that's around like
300k
so i know people like pomp think it's
going to a million i'm not i'm not that
full but i'm not full-blown bitcoin
maximalist right now
but i do just think it's gonna because
such be such a superior sort of value
i mean peter schiff tweeted today that
he finally accepted him but he was wrong
about bitcoin as an april fools
i think the jokes can be on him in like
a few years and he actually does accept
it
if he let me ask you about that let me
ask you about like is i think
so there's this narrative right that
bitcoin is the new gold
and i find it so fascinating how
they say it's easier to sell bitcoin as
an investment to your generation
than it is to sell gold as an investment
i mean you even said at the beginning of
this um
in the beginning of the podcast you said
um you know
you can't carry it around with you it's
difficult to transact in so
although it's pretty gold it's nice and
shiny um
you know it's not really something which
the next generation are gonna care that
much about bitcoin is an easier sell
don't you think
yeah literally no no one cares about
gold in anyone who i know
i think bitcoin in my era look at okay
it's a perfect example
peter schiff has a son called spencer
the guy's the biggest bitcoin maximus
i've ever seen
he's all in on bitcoin 100 bitcoin i
think that really kind of does show that
kind of stark difference
between somebody like spencership who's
way younger in university right now
this dad who's proper into bitcoin you
know now and he's
i don't know what the ship is probably
like 50 60 now so it's kind of the point
where
the younger generation's just embracing
bitcoin now if you have asked kids about
my
my age about bitcoin most of them are
going to have no clue just because you
know they're that young
they're not really interested in stuff
now but older and older
it's going to be kind of bitcoin will be
way more accepted than gold 100
you know the older you get you're going
to get people your friends are going to
be
let's say in at least five years your
friends are going to be
bugging you about how to invest i'm
absolutely telling you they're going to
be bugging you because you have
all the answers and i mean
even my family have been bugging me
about bitcoin and
i don't have all the answers um you know
i have some of the answers i have
don't have all of them but your friends
are going to be absolutely bugging you
um
but anyway why do you why do you think
then people like peter schiff can't get
on board even people like warren buffett
what's the problem well
i think instead of stuck in the past you
know they live with gold
for their whole life and a brand new
revolutionary digital currency comes
along they've seen the growth of the
internet and
in the one sense from the early 2000s to
now as many people i mean
like you're asian those people have seen
the growth of the internet now
yeah but it's all they've all seen it
progress
but i think especially when you're older
you may be in like 70s 60s it's a lot
harder to accept
especially being really passionate about
saying gold your whole life
even if you start to kind of crave into
bitcoin you're always going to incent to
always reject it
rejects it just because one thing in
your mind it's always like
gold is physical i can see gold i can i
can hold it i can hold it up
i can break it whatever that may be but
i actually have it i can have it still
running in my room i can have a story in
my vault
i've got it in it physically whenever
they struggle see bitcoin is selling
something which is on the internet so
you or or in the bitcoin network so they
struggle to see how you can actually
touch it
and how it has physical value like i'm
recording on the mac right now
i can touch my i can touch i can you
know do the keyboard whatever
or doing a mouse but the point is that
this is all physical and they struggle
to accept
that and stuff's just moving online it's
all moving online now
they just can't see that all happening
and they just they just can't accept it
so in a sense i think they've had a bit
stuck in the past and maybe they were
great once
but maybe they're kind of like falling
behind the times now
yeah i think it's so hard when you made
your fortune and you made your wealth
doing one
thing and then something new comes along
and it's just easier to just say
no that's rubbish because you don't want
to have to adopt
and and sorry adapt and change and they
always say you can't teach an old dog
new tricks
so maybe you know it's something like
that i mean even my dad
when tesla um invested into bitcoin
i i was going crazy i was like wow this
is so insane
and i told my dad and his first response
was
so when are you selling and i'm like oh
you don't get it
this means hold even tighter you know um
so i yeah i think it's so interesting um
and
i think you know i i was actually
telling my grandfather i mean he's
he's 93. i was telling him about bitcoin
and um
he thought it was criminal and he his
first response was does your father know
what's going on
it's crazy you know um so what are you
holding then you're holding bitcoin
right
can you tell us anything else yes i'm
having bitcoin ethereum right now and i
got some kind of funky tokens some
people sent me on on the ethereum
network
so i've just already got bitcoin
ethereum right now it's probably like a
six or sixty forty split right now
so i just i'm really big on crypto in
the one sense i think it's the next kind
of store of wealth
i do think bitcoin is going to be a
place where it's always going to be that
store
you know you see mass and adoption sets
that people might be able to pay with
bitcoin
and you know i think as the sun's people
talk about the risk that bitcoin might
get deregulated or regulation will come
in
i think governments love bitcoin because
it's open to secure they can see all the
transactions happening on it
i just think the only reason governments
would regulate it or do anything
incentive regulation
is just to get a fair share of the taxes
side of it yeah that's all
all the only thing governments are
really concerned about they just want
their fair share of the taxes
you're gonna for example you might see a
bitcoin being abandoned
um pakistan or somewhere where in the in
the east
completely get somewhere here which is a
lot more you know completely open
you know open speech you know you can
have protests
you've got all this kind of free speech
the western in the west so it's kind of
like they won't
it'd be harder to really push a ban on
bitcoin but i don't think it's
risk of a ban now it's just where they
want their taxes and where they want to
introduce something
i do think that's the only really real
risk with bitcoin
is also supply bitcoins completely based
on supply and demand
you have to have supply and demand for
bitcoin with somewhere like tesla
if tesla builds a gigafactories tesla
does well in autonomy
attest makes in billions of trillions
wherever from all their business sectors
tesla stock prices rise with it
obviously but comparison and bitcoin it
does have to be that mass
adopted so in a sense you've got to have
constant supply and demand for it
and yeah i think i think that's what i'm
seeing right now it's more and more
people starting to hear about bitcoin
and realize bitcoin
has come away from that lesser legal
activity now and all that sort of
illegal activity and it's now talking to
how it's about has
such a phenomenal story of value so i do
think bitcoin's got the most potential
of bitcoin ethereum i think ethereum's
potential is where you've got the whole
network
everything built around that network you
should transact with it you can buy
paint you can write online paintings now
for nfts
you can find all these amazing kind of
things all these funky things
you can buy new kind of coins on the
ethereum network are they gonna be worth
anything or not that's a different
question
such a whole kind of whole layer around
the theorem
then you're gonna see ethereum two and
then hopefully you're gonna get gas
prices lowered
so i think that's a one thing stopping
the theorem from really having a
breakout
it's just how much gas costs because
it's kind of insane
a few years ago like last year it would
cost a few bucks
that's like 20 30 bucks if i wanted to
buy a coin or whatever
so i think is if you get the gas prices
down with their room too
but all the new updates coming to
ethereum then you can really see mass
adoption on the side of ethereum
so i do think that's where to
potentialize i say longer term bitcoin
does have the most chance of being
successful
i think if a theorem can get in there
near the
popularity of bitcoin and people start
to accept as kind of a whole transaction
network
then you could see a theorem really take
off alongside bitcoin
yeah i think you make a really
interesting point just going back to the
point about um
regulation um because i think it does
come down to governments kind of wanting
their fair share and wanting to get
their cut
um because like you said you know there
was this concern initially that bitcoin
was
um the best answer the best vehicle for
criminal activity and as we know with
blockchain technology that's obviously
not the case
everything can be tracked and traced and
cash is far better
um you know to use if you want to like
launder money or whatever it is
um so yeah that narrative has definitely
been broken down i think
so in nigeria they they they put some
they put some heavy regulations there
which stopped people from trading and
then i ended up trading at a premium but
i think they actually went back on that
i need to check it out but i think they
reversed it because they sort of
realized that these are something called
to even get more bitcoin everything like
90 grand a bitcoin
even that's really illegal in nigeria
just so they can actually own bitcoin
so i think yeah in african countries is
there for bitcoin
you know bitcoin could be a solution to
africa some of africa's poverty
in the sense i don't go fully with some
of that kind of argument i see people
always sing saying our book was the
answer to africa after the super poor
in itself so i think the first thing
about afro is actually getting all that
technology into it
so i mean like starlink could really
solve that as you can guess it without
building all the buyers
you kind of all beam down from the skies
because they said more
more spacex rockets into the sky which
gets startling a huge advantage
so i think the main focus of africa in a
sense is just technology
um and growing but then if you start
getting get in the face with more
technology going to africa which i think
is really last continent
to be taken up to some sort of modern
standards how
how the west is living or maybe
somewhere in asia or
or even china in that sense as soon as
you get kind of that standard sign
taking up for all the african countries
then you could see bitcoin become a
solution to africa and helping more
people get our poverty in africa
but that's that's my view on that i
don't know what your original thing was
well no i totally agree with you that's
one of the main things actually that
drew me to this space initially
it was literally blockchain in africa
like bitcoin aside there's this whole
blockchain in africa movement
and i'm actually fascinated by it
because there's this idea that
africa are going to skip industrial
revolutions and
you know are just going to be totally um
unbanked and that'd be absolutely fine
but i think that's where defy comes in a
little bit and i'm not i'm really kind
of uncomfortable with d5
i like it i get it but i think it's
really hard to i find it quite hard to
navigate and you know and know what's
good and what's not honestly
there's just been so many rug pulls but
um i was actually
doing an interview with a company called
um i think it's called zend finance
and um they're huge in nigeria and i
didn't know this but apparently there
are
there are limits about how much you're
maybe allowed to spend or trade i can't
remember but apparently there's like a
hundred dollar a day limit on on
on something in nigeria and i was
absolutely blown away and these d5
protocols are out there
making a difference and you know i
thought that was insane honestly
yeah i mean i think d5 has got potential
by you i just find it quite hard to you
know go through all of it
yes see what is which what is good or
bad so i think
one day i need you to see a full blown
thing into d5
i just spend like the instead of looking
at stocks it's just like d5 d5 d3
then kind of get your head around it and
actually decide what's good or bad i
mean right now i just stick with kind of
my core kind of thing which is bitcoin
in my in my kind of mind i've got my
i've got my theory my 640 split
but i'm super big on kind of bitcoin
that's like the main thing i think i
actually own some um
gbtc which is basically bitcoin on the
ethereum network
it's backed by one bitcoin so you
basically follow the exact price of
bitcoin
and i said i own some of that as my
bitcoin holding as well i think
nice that's amazing i'm sure there have
been some amazing comments by the way
just to let you know
i'm sure somebody will um give you a
defy
give you some d5 tips in the comments
i'm sure someone will reach out to you
so guys
follow young investor he's absolutely
amazing and give him some deep eye tips
but i wanted to ask you have you were
you following the robin hood scandal
with gme and amy
yeah i mean i was kind of vocal in the
kind of robin hood scandal
i think gme i mean it's just like 100
something dollars right now i think
the first one i think the first run of
wall street bets
it's brilliant you know it's squeezing
it to a short as they manipulated your
stock prices for such a long time
in a sense now it's becoming kind of a
new face of the best thing which i can't
say you don't want
it's going to face investing as wall
street bets that's not you're not doing
i mean look at you know something like
keith mcgill who's wrong kissy you know
um all on reddit and all that the really
first person to be proper into and
gme at four dollars he'd done his
research he concluded was super duper
undervalued
and he's done like he did hours of dcf
modeling on on the thing
on all his live streams from back in the
day there's one live stream which only
got some like one person for like a four
hour live stream in the chat
so i think he was just looking at those
stocks as the kind of thing where
jimmy's super undervalued and wall
street and he started posting on wall
street bets read it
the wall street bets was it is really
first of a big pump of wall street bets
to actually profit influencing the stock
market and going beyond the realm of
penny stocks
and into the big cap stocks it's like
worth a two billion dollars
such as gma i don't think the second the
second time around which you'll sing
with a lot of the companies maybe it's
kind of bit where
it's become the face of investing and
then so many people lost money from the
jeremy's uh all the gme saga yeah
there's some random security guys like
2060 he said 11 000
loan which was all his net worth in
which he had done it all on
to put him all in jimmy like three
hundred bucks which is a bit
it's coming that's insane and you lost
it all obviously
so it's kind of thing where it's kind of
becoming the new face of it
whether that's good or not i do think
robin are blocking the trains
it's like super there's something shady
going on in the sense
but it's time to think whether it's
actually robinhood or not because
originally then i was kind of all set on
its robin hood but after
doing a bit more research into it it
seems in my eyes uh somebody at citadel
who's holding the trainings
for robin hood it wasn't just robin had
affected robertson got
slack but we bought they all shut they
should all shut it down apart from so
far
so i do think that looking at all um
i think maybe there's something shady
going on that might be through citadel
so it's something like citadel
securities which is the transaction of
all the kind of
inflow of orders which i'm sending every
day or whatever you send every day
and which is transacting them by
themselves and then citadel which is a
hedge fund
they both own the same company but they
said there's no collusion there's
obviously some sort of collusion
the ceo is the exact same with both
companies there's absolutely no
inclusion they said so
there's definitely been collusion
somewhere in my eyes in the network
with the problem solely to blame for
that i don't i don't i'm not too sure if
that's really the truth of it
yeah i was watching um an interview that
the c
ceo did i think was his name vlad
vladimir or something like that
yeah vlad so he didn't interview i think
it was with cnbc and
do you ever get when you're watching
someone really closely and you're trying
to listen to every single word they're
saying
to really try and understand and i swear
to you he said nothing
i really got no you know they asked them
was it problem liquidity no it wasn't a
problem with liquidity
um and literally absolutely nothing
you know it was so insane um but also
there are some questions
for you in the chat so i'm wondering
would you want to do a little ama really
quickly are you cool with that
far right okay guys so if you have any
questions for
our young investor drop them in the chat
now so
there are some really interesting ones
um and one which i wanted to ask you but
i actually forgot myself
so here we go wondering if he had any
issues opening up trading accounts
because of his age this kid is
impressive
totally agree or really cool so did you
have any
uh age restrictions and even on twitter
is there an age minimum
age so like i'm in like the twitter
restrictions we're just you know just
right now but yeah with the trading
account kind of their story so i just
got my
mom to open the trading account so just
do all of that now my mom's got like no
clue what i do my trading account is
just like
whatever you know she's got absolutely
no clue about anything about finance
at all so i just got my mom to open it
so i can do it myself obviously because
i don't pay taxes and i'm not yet 18.
i think it should be like something like
16 just because that's 16 you start
paying taxes anyway
so it's kind of like well if you pay
taxes you should be allowed to invest in
stock market legally anyway
about 18 then i'll probably i'd probably
just transfer it all to my
when i open a new account at 18. i'll
just get it all transferred over there
and just send it directly um i think you
can't say your stocks now
i'm really doing the state so i had to
check with my broker in the uk
i love that you have that that's so
funny yeah i mean it's totally the same
thing i remember when i was when i was
younger this sounds really weird because
usually i'm always the youngest in the
room so this is a really strange
experience
um but when i was opening up a facebook
account back in like 2006 2007
i wasn't old enough either so i feel
like most the people on social media
aren't
on old enough everybody sort of like
jokes about their age but there are a
few more questions someone says how old
is he
it's a goal for those that don't know
30. uh by 10 13 like two weeks ago now
so yeah it's been so yeah so 13 two
weeks ago last sunday
and then i got my new um mac for my like
birthday which is like a warm up for the
birthday present so that's what i do i'm
waiting to use on now
so before i'd used to use like my uh my
little phone
but now it's like really all improved
quality you know got the microphone and
everything
so really improved quality in terms of
your camera in terms of what's my
what's your first big loss and for how
did you react i don't like
i haven't had a you know like a big big
loss which would be
sizeable i might have lost like 10 more
stocking i've sold before
i haven't really experienced that big
loss i'm sure i will at some point but i
think
just because you've invested for nine
months it's always been a super bull
market for the last nine months
i don't think it's kind of a bit harder
unless you're going super all in on
penny stocks
or kind of a hype play i might have
gotten to maybe
one or two kind of stocks for like i
don't know 50 bucks into it's kind of a
super sweat play where i might have lost
i know like 10 percent or whatever
there's nothing really which in my core
portfolio which i've actually lost loads
of money on
okay cool let's have a look what else
we've got here um so many questions all
right i'm gonna i'm trying to
get some friendly ones here we go what
do you look for when investing in
altcoins
specifically defy tokens we did kind of
touch on this but go for it
yeah so when i kind of look i'm looking
for something which has been around for
a while number one i'm not i don't want
to buy something
completely new so use socks it's kind of
the main thing i mean
i look at socks and stuff which was
original experiment about one or two
years ago
super not hyped at all so socks has
started seven for twelve dollars there's
an experiment it's literally experiment
with the craziest uni swap
hayden adam jones and all the guys over
there
and they did this huge experiment and
the guy i know who i did i think
once mike the maurice he brought into he
brought some like 10 socks that sound
like 12 bucks
he's like yes he's what i call the only
socks maximalist
in the entire world he's like full blown
socks he wears socks he wears uni socks
on it
he wears like thousand dollar socks he's
like full blown that he's like full
blown socks
so i think unlike something it can be
copied like there's stuff on the network
can be not
exactly copied by some of the codes or
something like uni socks
yeah somebody else can release their own
kind of socks i think something like
that which has been on network for
way longer than all the new kind of
things coming into it
it's something which is really cool and
i've i haven't brought any efts yet
i'm kind of browsing some like i know
kelly from hyperchain troy interviewed
he when he buys nfts it's not because he
wants to make money on them he actually
appreciates
what they are what the artwork is so i'm
not super involved in d5 right now
i do i just i think i just need to do a
few miles of digging into it
i'm going to conclude what is that
greatest what's the best and what is the
worst
why do you think it's more maybe
established stuff right now
yeah well you're getting a great fan
base here so i'm sure some no
i'm sure somebody's going to come and
help you with some defy info um
here's another good one where did it go
i want to put it up on the screen
here we go what's his hottest penny
stock
drop yeah so the kind of one
like one which i got super high
conviction i am like a few it's like
five percent of my portfolio
i mean it's super high indexes peak it's
not a fully
full-blown penny stock but it's around
300 million dollar market cap so it will
move like a penny stock
also one of the things i will add to
people as i talked about earlier
is how well the stock price holds up in
terms of you get a correction or
something you know the whole market
scene in town turn
peak during when all the growth stocks
like tesla they're all down like five
percent plus
people sounds like 0.88 so i also think
peak's really the only penny stock i've
seen
where people invest and actually know
what they're invested in they've
actually done their loads of research
for it
so i think people are like top one i
won't repeat everything i said but if
you just wind it back then you can see
what i was saying i'm gonna go
all right and just last question for you
um because i want to dig in on this
right at the end do you plan to leave
school asap ah what great question
no i like i'm probably gonna say school
to like six months or something but
further education university maybe not
maybe i'll just see how it goes
but yeah i think i feel like some of my
friends did homeschooling
like after they left primary school or
something yeah i didn't really keep in
touch with them they're not
super good friends and so i think home
school is coming we just kind of lose
social contact with people
i think it's always good to be in
contact with people you know have that
kind of social interaction
social interaction because we see with
you know covered when you don't interact
with people and how much it damages
people's mental health and all that kind
of stuff
so i think school's always like a great
place to go to but maybe not even
maybe not further education i think
you're
so intelligent and i think that you
are in the most incredible position i've
ever
seen someone of your age be in you know
not just you're not not just having an
understanding of finance and being able
to trade but also your understanding of
the world
um you know like i was saying earlier on
twitter there's so much
conversation um conversation about the
world right like
even conversation about covid and how we
as people should react to that
you know and whether it's our
responsibility or your responsibility
and all this stuff and i just think
having exposure to these kind of
conversations
i'm just honestly so blown away i think
you're absolutely incredible somebody's
just written lol she's interviewing a
millionaire kid already
i mean i won't ask you about that but no
i i think you're
honestly so fantastic and um
i just want to wish you the best of luck
with everything that you do and also
one thing that i will say is um just
continue to do what you're doing don't
let anybody
pull you off track don't let you know
people will be jealous
and just stay focused do what you're
doing
um because i i've never ever seen
someone so
intelligent and just so on it and so
worldly at such a young age i think it's
fantastic
so there you go those are my thoughts um
what are you up to now and how can
people reach out to you yeah so you can
watch my youtube channel which is young
investor
i've had a few guests on recently go
watch watch go watch like three videos
ago
like i was doing those stock videos so
you're watching on there or you can
follow me out at investor2 on twitter
or just just like a young investor i
should be like near this top or first
search result when you look that up so
yeah that's really my like two main
feeds and i've also got discord group
there's a link
on the pinned um comment and my twitter
there you go i want to thank you so much
it's been such a pleasure and um
guys don't forget to follow him he's a
little genius he'll make you a genius
um so guys give him a follow and thank
you all for tuning in i will see you
next week bye
uh